hello there watching The Press preview a
first look of course at what is on the
front pages time to see what's making
the headlines with the political editors
of the guardian and the Sam peppercura
and Harry Cole who are with us from now
until just before midnight welcome back
to both of you so to the front pages
then let's start with the Metro it says
England kicked off their World Cup
campaign with a historic win but it was
opponents Iran who won praise for their
protests over human rights violations at
home The Sun Also splashing on England's
World Cup victory picturing opening goal
scorer Jude Bellingham the guardian
leads with a report that Justice
secretary Dominic Robb is facing fresh
questions over his behavior during his
first stint in the role The Daily Mail
reporting that MPS have been told for
the first time they can host Christmas
parties and claim for refreshments and
decorations
the eye reports that EU officials say
number 10 and the treasury are guilty of
Wishful Thinking over claims they can
pursue a closer relationship with the EU
without adopting laws such as freedom of
movement
telegraph's front page is a report that
labor leader secure starmer will tell
the confederation of British business
the CBI that Britain must end its
economic dependence on immigration
the time says Britain's leading
Specialists have predicted that patients
with Advanced cancers will see their
life expectancy double within the decade
thanks to new treatments the financial
times leads with reports that senior
Walt Disney Executives led a campaign
against chief executive Bob chapek over
the summer that resulted in his ousting
and replacement with predecessor Bob
Iger
and remind by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
or our guests let's head shall we to
pipakura and Harry Cole hello to both of
you so lots of football to talk about
England and Wales both in action on the
uh on the same day
um Harry let's go to the the Metro first
of all shall we bravery of lions
elsewhere too um talking about Iran in
fact and a hit for six for for England
um but a suggestion that the rainbow
armbands went well the Iranians made you
know the most Brave example to us all
effectively
yeah it seems the fa uh Southgate Harry
Kane got themselves into a bit of a
tears earlier it was slightly
unnecessary I think
um sort of Rao it was marched itself all
the way up to the top of the hill and
then back down somewhat which was very
embarrassing but actually I think all
this probably could have been sorted out
a few days ago
um that said
um you know this has been a you know
there's two stories around this world
cup won the actual football and two the
controversy surrounding it
um despite getting themselves in a right
old mess pre-match
um England did absolutely smash it on
the pitch
um so it's gonna be you know I I feel
it's gonna be one of those World Cups
where the longer it goes on the better
perhaps England and possibly Wales more
likely England do the less we're going
to hear about the controversy and the
more we're going to hear about the
football but um it's um I I can't
remember a World Cup like this where
there's been so much uh you know
controversy around it perhaps there
should have been in 2018 around um when
in Russia I remember there being you
know a ministerial boycott but the level
of um you know sort of uh almost
self-censorship in terms of the BBC and
going out of their way to not show the
the opening ceremony to make a big deal
a big play out of explaining the
controversies around the tournament but
I think the that's beginning to fade
tonight and the and the action on the
pitch is beginning to become the story
and you know you know in some senses
Wales not making the fronts of so many
papers but a late penalty
um you know saw them with a great result
tonight as well for the first time since
1958 Pippa um but uh you know all of
those controversies there was a real
concern that it would distract the
players you know right from the the
rainbow issues through to
um fans who didn't use the FIFA app
today and many who missed the start of
the game you know food as well in the
stadium at the fan Park in in Doha as
well
um you know it is the controversy do you
think something that that will stick
with the with the tournament throughout
or as Harry said will it fade is the
football comes to the four
I think if you're a guitar just now
having gone through all that effort to
win the bid for the World Cup in the
first place and to obviously very
unusually be held
um in the winter or our winter because
of the the extreme temperatures in in
the summer out there you might be
thinking really at this point was it all
worth it they spent 200 billion quid on
it I mean that's that's sort of I think
Russia was about 20 billion so it's
substantially higher than previous World
Cups
um and yet if their aim was to try and
sort of present themselves as sort of a
modern Western Nation or even as a sort
of the most open-minded open to visitors
uh part of the of the gulf then so far
that seems to have absolutely Fallen
flat on its Pace because as you say the
early the early hours the early days of
the contest had been overshadowed by
Rise about uh their own laws on
homosexuality on the services and
provided to visitors alcohol being
banned and the spotlights on some of the
politics around it all
um I think Harry's right though I do
think that as the contest gets underway
and people get more into the football
some of the sort of political
difficulties you know the sort of the
moment the row has been had it's kind of
kind of fizzled out
um a bit of a damp squib really the the
in the end the the armband protest
um when you consider particularly as the
Metro has done on the front page
um this was the measures that the
Iranian team have taken not singing
their album and criticizing the regime I
think the captain did
um you know it looks a bit ineffectual
in comparison to that
um but I think ultimately if we get
games like we did today British fans at
least Welsh and English fans
um even the Scots amongst us might have
a an eye on the Telly on some occasions
um we'll be focusing more and more on
the football and less and less on the
politics yes well the uh the eye has
some of those similar issues on the
front in it in its picture story but
underneath um is about the questions of
how close we should be to Europe and how
we go about it this paper suggesting
that EU officials have told the eye that
number 10 in the treasury are guilty of
Wishful Thinking over claims they can
pursue a closer relationship with the EU
without adopting laws such as close to
regulation and freedom of movement so
what what is the background to all of
this Sunday Times Swiss model story The
denials today from Rishi sunik at the
CBI Harry where did this all come from
well it all came with the chancellor
basically
um a couple late last week he went on
and did an interview where he basically
said that over the course of the next 10
years that um he will you know he hopes
that you know trade barriers with Europe
can be sort of melted away I think was
the was the expression he used and trade
had become more with our closest
neighbors become a frictionless now it
appears that he has uh followed this up
with some private conversations around
Whitehall perhaps in the years of
journalists so they ended up on the
front page on Sunday Times no one is
denying uh that the chancellor was the
source of that story we put it I've been
putting it to them since Sunday morning
uh and they you know they use this line
if we're not getting into private
discussions which is normally Whitehall
code for yeah we're bang to rights we're
not going to pour any more petrol on
this fire now Richie sunac has been
greeted by a pretty severe backlash from
the brexiteers in the party
um concerns that perhaps they could be
outflanked on the right at an election
you know they're already getting
hammered by labor you know five six
seven points for reform or a resurgent
Nigel farage on the right and they're
really looking at a proper routing at
the next election so soon that turns up
in Birmingham this morning determined to
slay this story we've done it up
tomorrow as what it was which is a bit
of a slap down for the chancellor you
know we're not doing this stop talking
about it this is not on our agenda and a
fairly Chase and Jeremy Hunt I think um
perhaps you know he's been out of he's
been out of Frontline politics really
for a few years perhaps a little rusty
perhaps feeling a little bit bruised
that's the comments he made ended up on
the front page on Sunday times but
frankly I think it's in the public
interest if if politicians are privately
discussing this sort of thing totally
fair game to tell the world that well
you say that but David Davis was on the
radio this evening he said he got a call
at 8pm on Saturday night from the mail
on Sunday who'd got whiff of the Sunday
time story and immediately I was putting
the phone down on the mail and he called
the chancellor who categorically denied
it was him and said you know Tom I saw
that it was it's quite carefully worded
the chancellor said that's not our plans
that's not category denying that he had
discussed the possibility of a one day
hoping for it to be the fact is it fears
that the chancellor ran his mouth off
and has got burnt for that um you know
sort of they're dancing on the head of a
pin a little bit about exactly you know
you know who's denying what exactly but
frankly the story came from somewhere
the Sunday Times don't put a story like
that on the front without it being you
know from the horse's mouth so to speak
okay well the sun picks up on that as
you said uh Rishi rapping hunts knuckles
as it were on this Swiss brexit beard
um but as we heard from the CBI and
we'll go on to that with uh secure
stammer in just a moment there is an
issue of not enough workers to fill
vacancies there is an issue of the
Northern Ireland protocol you know still
holding up
um you know any further relationship
with the European Union so how do we get
rid of some of these trade barriers uh
Pippa do you think and try to smooth and
Export and import issues that have that
have happened since brexit
I think the single biggest issue to be
resolved as um was obviously mentioned
at the CBI today was the the remaining
uh sending issues around the Northern
Ireland protocol and showing that that
can
um that trade across
um the border between the Iowa the
island of Ireland and Northern Ireland
can can flow freely and effectively with
both sides happy and I think that would
be a really you know if you can get if
you can get that under the belt and show
that it's a possibility
um then you'd like to think that that uh
both sides will be able to move on when
it comes to sort of the broader trading
partnership and I think on the hunt
stuff I mean it's no surprise what his
view is I mean he's been saying it
privately for for months and months and
months
um and even went on the radio last week
and talked about
um wanting to remove the vast majority
of the trade barriers exist between us
and the EU rather meaning outside the
single market so um this this is
obviously his is his longer term view
um it doesn't necessarily mean it's
happening right now and I think that
ultimately
um there will be a desire for trade to
operate as smoothly as possible but
number 10 was quite clear today on their
red lines they there would be no return
to the single Market there'd be no
return to freedom of movement there'd be
no alignment with rules
um that are imposed
um on uh by Brussels or any what they
regarded as unnecessary payments or
anything which puts British trade
um deals with other countries at risk so
you know that's quite a lot of red lines
when it comes to reaching smoother trade
it's through the trade agreements and
actually doesn't leave that much space
for anything which would make it
actually a significant macroeconomic
difference when it comes to trading
trading with the EU so
um but all the suggestions today despite
despite this story bubbling up over the
weekend all the suggestions today is
that that smoother trade is something
that is a long-term ambition rather than
anything which is actually you know
being discussed actively in the in the
corridors or even the state rooms of
number 10 and number 11 right now it's
it's a debate that's getting started
um but not one that is anywhere near
completion yes and if we look at the The
Daily Telegraph
um one of the biggest issues there
obviously was about migrant labor and
its role in increasing productivity and
then here is secure stama who will also
tell the CBI that the UK needs to wean
itself off migrant labor real hardening
then do you think of the stance from
labor on this policy
absolutely I think this is a really
important moment actually in and I hate
to go full X Factor and talk about a
journey but the kiss Thomas Journey from
you know devout people's vote
campaigning second referendum let's
let's use every tool in the Box to undo
brexit to you know future future Prime
Minister wannabe and he's putting a real
marker down tomorrow it's remarkable
that he actually sounds um you know
almost harder line on migration and and
and and and Britain's borders than
perhaps some in the in the new cabinet
uh might be if you push them on it um a
really significant intervention from
starmer he's going to say look you know
it's almost sort of he's putting some
distance here between him and Blair him
and mandelson him and Gordon Brown who
basically used Mass migration from
Europe to try and kick start and grow
Britain through you know by inflating
GDP uh by opening up the borders he's
saying no you cannot do that and at the
same time he's being quite tough with
business he's saying look at the same
time you know we have to expect you to
be doing the training to be paying
people properly to be you know this
could be a Boris Johnson speech from any
from any moment of his Premiership where
he was trying to make this case that
actually we're controlling our borders
but you've got the business people have
to pay people properly and train people
properly
um because you know you're not going to
have that access to cheap labor really
important moment for Kirsten I wonder
how it's going to go down with the left
of his party well let's ask Pippa with
one additional question if you don't
mind I mean Shakira starma will say we
need to start investing more and
Training Up workers who are already here
you know what about the farming
Community they tried that didn't they
with British people doing the fruit
picking and all those other jobs a lot
of it sent to Rob what was it 600
million pounds of food that was thrown
away because it wasn't harvested and
people didn't last eight hours you know
is there an argument that britons don't
want to do certain jobs in this country
a role that was filled by migrant
workers or is that an old-fashioned
attitude now
well it's certainly something which uh
people claim isn't it but this is a
discussion that's been going on behind
um scenes with labor for some time now
Rachel Reeves in particularly the shadow
chancellor has been pushing this idea of
saying look if we have workers here
economically inactive people here that
could work what we need to be doing is
encouraging them back into the labor
market and as Harry rightly says part of
that equation is um but part of that is
has to be um on business and making sure
that the training and skills and
development are there and also the pay
get good quality jobs labor of stress
but the other bit of it is that if you
look at the figures and there are
millions of people like it's more than
two million people that are currently
economically inactive and out of the
labor market because of their health and
we hope that the readings of this in
kyostarma's labor conference speech when
he talked about public services signed
public services that can that can
deliver being key to growth because for
example you have two million people that
are economically inactive because of
their health if you can if they're
waiting for operations or procedures the
single best way to get them back into
the labor market quickly is to drive
down those waiting lists which currently
six or seven million people long and
still implies across education as well
of course if the training and skills
agenda there the funding is there then
you're going to be able to get more
people into the workplace so it's about
the bigger the holistic approach not
just being a responsibility of business
to drive growth and to and to pay better
and create better conditions but also on
the state to make sure that the public
sector is adequate is working adequately
in order to be able to free up those
people that they want to work really
inactive sorry to button we've got stuff
to pack in after the break as well I do
apologize and lots more to come as I
said why you will pay for MPS Christmas
parties according to the mail back with
that and more in just a moment
[Music]
you're watching the Press preview we are
joined once again Peppa by pippakura and
Harry Cole welcome back to both of you
Peppa we go to your story in the
guardian on Dominic Robb tell us more
and this is yet another allegation about
Dominic Robb Justice secretary and
Deputy Prime Minister and his behavior
towards civil servants I mean these have
been rumbling on now for uh the best
part of 10 days uh number 10 I think
after the budget was hoping that they'd
gone away despite the fact that there
was two formal complaints put in
um which are currently being invested
not currently being investigated because
nobody's been appointed yet to
investigate them but will will be
investigated and the latest story is
that Dominic Robb behaves so badly in a
meeting with the home office during his
first dentist Justice secretary that is
Department of top official a woman
called Antonio Romeo who's the prominent
secretary there had to personally call
up home office counterparts afterwards
to apologize I should say that my other
departments denied that this apology
call took place and just suggests that
their departments work hand in glove and
they're a regular follow-up calls
um after the cross-departmental meetings
but my sources are clear that this call
took place after alleged per Behavior
badly and inappropriately behaved behave
that he behaves so badly and
inappropriate Italy at the high level
meeting earlier this year
are you keeping a tally of how many
people whose jobs you may have cost
I'm not sure that's fair well Boris
Johnson was one I suppose that started
but uh yes you're right um anyway Daily
Mail you pay for MP's Christmas parties
um tell us more Harry
as well as the stories you read you just
think what uh how many meetings had the
people sitting where this got signed off
how many email chains were there where
someone thought this was a good idea and
no one saw this front page coming
um so the MP's expenses regime pretty
strict in 2009 MPS can't really claim
they can claim for sort of office office
upkeep and within that it appears this
year they're allowed to play for
Christmas decorations and um no booze
but um the cost of entertaining your
staff for a Christmas party in your
office very strange one I wonder how
long that will last
um in the in the fullness of time given
the the given the circumstances given
the economic mood the cost of living
crisis
um any suggestion that MPS you know are
on the take they tend to take a pretty
dim view with pretty quickly once it's
been exposed so I wonder how long that
that perk will last Harry Cole
peppercare thank you both very much
Steve thank you